is one of the most talented players that
has come out of Alabama one of the most
talented players to play in college
football and I cannot wait to see what
he's gonna do with the next level here
courtesy of Autotrader national champion
and one of the greatest humans that I
have been told exists on the planet so
I'm thrilled to me to a Tongo by Lola
good to see you - how are you sir good
so it's very interesting I always
appreciate this this does happen to my
career from time to time you sat down
and you just said what as you sat down
you said that you wanted to ask me
questions what if you just asked me
questions on I was getting ok some more
I'm more than more than happy cuz you're
coming to the next level I've been I've
been here at the next level the NFL for
about 16 17 years is there any anything
I'm actually gonna ask you questions
about your profession okay do you have
one you want to ask they talk about you
instead because again I have been I
don't know if you're aware of it but
I've been offering unsolicited to sense
your way about what position you should
have made back in djenne I think you
made the absolute right decision thank
you and going to this next level we are
we in the NFL media for sure are waiting
for you to say the least
how are you feeling right now you look
great you're walking around moving
around great yeah I'm doing I'm doing
really good you know I think up to this
point all we're waiting for is is you
know the three-month mark which would
not be this upcoming Monday but the
following Monday following week Monday
okay you know that's when we get to do
the CT scan and then a follow up with
MRI um and then we get a good gauge you
know if it's good you know that and the
doctors are gonna kind of let us loose a
little more know we're gradually working
into you know hopefully a pro day you
know but for me I think my main focus is
is at the NFL Combine would be you know
my medical I'm not going over there to
win the 40 not going over there to win
the benchpress neither am i by the way
yes
so I'm my main focus is going in there
trying to do my best you know with the
interviews um and and hopefully win my
medical well I mean and it's interesting
folks might hear you say when you're mad
like that is exactly what your combine
is going to be I mean it's going to be
you're gonna see a bunch of doctors
you're gonna be shuttled you're gonna go
through maybe some tubes you're gonna be
poked and prodded in a manner in which
you probably never but you're you're
you're expecting that pretty much isn't
told that cuz that's exactly what's
gonna happen then they'll they'll put
you know you'll be put on a greased
board you'll be going through all of
these meetings with teams I've been
imagine during the day since it's now a
nighttime event now that you're there we
were hoping that you'd be out there
throwing for a prime-time event but you
you don't think you'll be able to do
anything physical until when like what's
part of your plan like what would you
won would you like it to be if
everything goes according to plan
yeah bit so I you know if everything
goes as planned
looking at hopefully doing a pro day
towards the ending of March you know
early April you know before the draft so
before the draft and then you go to the
draft and we'll see yeah well there you
go
do you looking around here in Miami yeah
what do you think do you like the city
man it's a beautiful place you know I I
mean I think we're we're we're staying
it's a little touristy well okay no but
we'd have to see you know because I mean
I don't know too much about where a lot
of the guys that you know play football
live around here so it could be
different in that as could be different
in that but it's Bureau I mean a
beautiful sunshine look like this right
here I mean because I'll just come out
and say it because I mean you're dancing
around it yeah they've been tanking for
you for about two years to it did you
hear the tank for two of stuff is that
what you think of that I mean it's
awesome you know you know when you grow
up as a little kid you know you you
dream of things like that you know so I
mean I'm honored you know it's it's it's
a privilege I know I'm putting you in a
little bit of a difficult spot and I
apologize for that too a tongue of Aloha
here on the Rich Eisen show but there
has been that conversation that the
minute that you looked off a safety to
beat Georgia in overtime you had you had
much of the National Football League at
hello what was that moment like for you
that night in that national championship
yeah yeah it was an amazing moment not
just for me and not just for my
teammates but it was amazing for my
family you know
for my parents to see how happy they
were that was that was my main thing you
know I just I just wanted to play
because I knew how happy it made it made
my parents ah meant to me my parents and
if they're the world you know and for me
it's not just something I say but it's
something that that I really mean but I
mean for you to be thrust into that
situation like that did that surprise
you that you were put into the game did
it surprise me
yeah that you were put into the game huh
well my my thing you know leading up you
know to that game was like you know just
just be ready you know and throughout
that entire season that was my mentality
just be ready I mean he didn't come the
third game it didn't come the six game
it didn't come the ninth game you know
eventually I felt like you know it was
gonna come in might have an opportunity
to also compete if you didn't come you
know their national champ championship
year that I would have a chance to
compete the following years and it's
amazing that Jalen Hertz is in the same
draft is you yeah you know it's amazing
how life works and and I just think the
way that he reacted to your situation
and the way that he went to Oklahoma and
did what he did makes me want to root
for him more I wonder what your
relationship is like with him yeah I
mean he's a tremendous athlete but I
mean an even better person you know like
when before Jalen left to go to Oklahoma
you know I I kind of seen him while I
was visiting with my academic advisor I
mean he kind of pulled me to the side
he's like you know hey let me talk to
you you know for a second you know and
the biggest thing he told me was you
know I I I feel you deserve everything
you have right now you know and you know
you just giving me all these compliments
or whatnot but his biggest thing was you
know you lead your guys to you know back
to the national championship and we'll
see each other at the top you know it's
so like just you know little things like
that words of encouragement and then you
know with my injuries this past year I
mean he's reached out and then even
before the first game you know he's
FaceTime me we've talked on the phone
first game this year of this collegiate
yeah yeah yeah he face times you yeah
yeah based on we're on FaceTime
I mean she's talking about it and then I
think even before he played Texas
even before we play text we we talked to
one another you know his thing was you
know like let's let's wake up the the I
guess the state of Texas because we play
Texas A&M I believe when they played the
Texas Longhorns right it's just amazing
it really is amazing and again to have
that sort of maturity the both of you at
your age is just again it's just a book
to to root for certainly in the draft up
upcoming this year so just I guess recap
here so you're feeling good you're gonna
get an update a week from Monday you'll
hopefully get that and then you start
planning a pro day will it be in Alabama
specifically Freesat you will have that
Alabama yeah and I ask this question of
Derek Henry on a previous show what's
the most pissed off you made Nick Saban
ever oh when I took the sack second in
26 international you mean the one that
you immediately made up for with an
amazing place puts you on the map that's
so walk me through how that what he said
to you if you can in a certain way on a
live TV broadcast I mean I could only
see it on camera you know how mad he was
that's probably the most pissed off
though I I think he's ever been at me
you squeezed in his headset so hard and
then you know like it was hard because
the emotion was like so mad to so happy
you know so fast for him and you know we
got into the locker room when everything
settled down I mean he was still snow
the same coach you know put me to the
side like what were you thinking you
know like taking the show on after you
won the game and you pick and confetti
out of your hair he still took a moment
yeah the moment to revisit yeah that
yeah being who he is I mean you know he
pulled me to the side he said you know
whoa
why did you take the sack right you know
and I thought it was good time to joke
with him you know side
we won the national championship so I
told him I told him well you know we
needed more room to throw the ball coach
you know and like he looked at me and
like I was laughing he's like that's not
funny
so I mean I don't know what else to do
in that situation I was like okay I'm
sorry coach so I shook his hand and he
just moved off I love that story
my favorite story the whole week so you
just figured you hang out like oh yeah
that was a good time to joke but it was
nope
it's never a good time I guess in that
respect okay so Autotrader is hooking up
and you're hooking out with Autotrader
to get you ready for becoming a pro what
is your relationship with auto trader
yeah so I'm here on behalf of auto
trader and you know for me coming from
Hawaii to Alabama yeah you know the
first thing you think of is how am I
gonna get from point A to point B and so
transportation was a big thing so I
talked to my parents you know with
finding a car so we went on auto trader
and I mean they they made car shopping
that much easier for us okay you know
and then with Kelly Blue Book
you know the pricing was just right for
me and my family so all we had to really
do was call up the dealership you know
say say we wanted to come and come down
there and look at the car went down
there and with the help of my
grandparents too you know I was able to
get my first first car you know and how
far is the venire near the nearest beach
to campus that you had met it's about
four hours that's a four hour drive man
that's a long way as a long way so
that's and so you're gonna bring this
now and that relationship with Auto
Trader and Kelly Blue Book to the next
level
oh there's no doubt there's no doubt I'm
bringing them with me to the next level
that's probably gonna be one of my first
big purchases do so right and then you
know just look around this town while
you're here at the Super Bowl just look
at the sights and sounds and you know
make a mental note maybe you might uh
find yourself back here just throwing
that out there
yeah I mean whatever team decides to
pick me I'll be grateful to them thank
you okay fantastic now when you are in
these meeting rooms what you should just
flip the script on your the teams that
are interviewing him you should say in
order to draft me now I know this is not
your style
in order to draft me you have to spell
my first full name right I don't think
I'd be drafted the crease port like hint
yeah like hand the pen - Brian Flores
and say go on the grease board coach you
know and pronounce and pronounce it
right what do you think no that's not a
good strong how they not it's like me
walking into the okay to the room with
the Raiders in telling Mark Davis to
spell my last name say my first name
it'd be hard alright so for everybody
how do you say you're your full name
tuning a mono la polla tunnel viola
that's long now
by the way Wow you can't do that when
you're on like Sunday Night Football but
when you're announcing what school
you're from from the University of
Alabama you'll already be into the next
snap with the rest of the team the rest
of the offense up the introduced to a
sounds bed at too late to a round of
applause for - oh thank you guys traitor
and also Kelly Blue Book good to see you
sir for more of the Rich Eisen show tune
- audience Channel 239 under red TV for
free on BR live or download the Rich
Eisen show app